il ya un truc qu'on fait pas assez dans
les têtes je pense qu'on ne trouvait pas
c'est cramé des bouquins en fait si là
pour ça non vous avez déjà vu un tel
torrent brut des livres ou pas et ben
voilà ça s'appelle du dépucelage
bon il ya des détecteurs de fumée et
tout donc on va y aller un peu à la
sadique
concrètement j'ai deux bouquins il ya un
bouquin il a été écrit par un belge et
un bouquin c'est moi qui l'ait écrit
comme sur un faux culs vous savez lequel
j'ai brûlé savez ce qu'on dit c'est les
meilleurs qui partent en premier alors
ça me fait un petit hit i man au coeur
daudet d'arracher une page de mon propre
but qu'un est cramé devant vous comme ça
en plus question pyromanie je suis pas
vous étonner c'est qu'avec ma gueule on
peut se poser des questions via ouais ça
part vite en vrille
on va arrêter pour éviter qu'ils aient
tous qu' une page bon l'expérience
s'arrête là parce que si je cram le
bouquin en fait là vous sortez tous
concrètement bon ce que je suis en train
de faire et c'est ce qu'on fait la
nature tous les jours c'est à dire là
j'ai arraché une page est cramé un tout
petit feu des lettres la nature c'est
une bibliothèque
la nature c'est une bibliothèque chaque
espèce est un livre et quand on détruit
une espèce c'est un livre qu'on détruit
bon là la page que j'ai cramer si vous
voulez les lettres qui a su elle existe
encore dans d'autres bouquins la valeur
d'un livre à l'aidant qu à votre avis
dans le papier ou dans les lettres
si on devait garder qu'un seul les
lettres ou le papier les lettres parce
que vous pouvez avoir un livre sans
papiers aujourd'hui c'est possible il ya
les pdf etc
ça c'est jouable mais un livre sans
l'être c'est pas possible
et les lettres d'ailleurs c'est ce
qu'ils font que les livres antique donc
nous sont parvenues c'est pas leurs
tablettes de cire c'est pas leurs
tablettes d'argile c'est leur lettre les
traditions orales et c'est ça c'est la
nature c'est la nature par micha on m'a
dit qu'il fallait dire mourra mais quand
je dis mourra personnes comprend quand
je dis michel non plus alors c'est chez
vous ça c'est visible à bruxelles au
musée fin de siècle
et oui je dis c'est chez vous vous avez
bien compris je suis français
personne n'est parfait
et la nature c'est une bibliothèque
c'est vraiment ça le sujet je voudrais
revenir donc ce bouquin du coup je le
garde
voilà j'ai gardé suis là parce que vous
allez voir qu'il est vachement
intéressant il a été écrit par un donc
un belge gunter pauli qui pose une idée
très simple c'est que pendant 300 ans on
a vécu dans l'idée que nature et
industrie on ne pouvait pas avoir les
deux c'est à dire que là où il ya de
l'emploi n'y a pas de nature c'est la
ville et là où il ya de la ville il ya
là où il ya de l'emploi pardon n'est pas
de nature c'est l'avis de la hoya de la
nature il n'y a pas d'emploi c'est la
campagne et on peut pas avoir les deux
natures et emploi c'est pas jouable et
ça fait trois cents ans qu'on vit dans
cette idée là que vous pouvez pas avoir
nature et prospérité en même temps qu'il
y en a forcément un des deux qui va
mourir et pour l'instant pas pour créer
la prospérité ont détruit la nature
en fait ça c'est un mensonge on peut
avoir les deux la nature c'est une
golden girls c'est ça c'est le premier
point voyez les tout en or leur qu'est
ce qu'on peut dire de la nature d'après
cette culture il cherchait pas trop loin
elle est bien gaulée bon la nature est
belle
la valeur économique de la beauté de la
nature ça saute aux yeux je veux dire un
appartement avec vue sur park a plus de
valeur qu'un appartement avec vue sur
parking jusque là et à new york
ils ont fait central park manhattan
c'est un des immobiliers les plus chers
au monde
ils ont quand même y mobiliser du
foncier pour faire central park et
central park c'est plus grand que monaco
on peut faire tenir monaco dans central
park qui est le foncier le plus cher au
monde heures mais si vous disiez ou new
york et en asie on crame tout et puis on
met des bâtiments ils diraient non donc
la beauté de la nature
c'est déjà une évidence comme tout comme
valeur économique mais je vais vous
montrer qu'en fait elle a aussi une
valeur bien au delà et pas seulement sa
beauté qu'elle la valeur au 21ème siècle
nature et emploi vont travailler
ensemble parce que la nature c'est le
meilleur économiste sur terre alors
entrant dans le vif du sujet ça c'est le
nouveau campus d'apple
ils sont pleins aux as ça leur a coûté 4
milliards quand il téléphone à leurs
banques apple la banque répond votre
compte et créditeurs du pib du qatar
plus le budget défense français et quand
je dis sa brique 1 et 10 mauvais exemple
ça c'est bagdad ça m'a influencé apple
est en fait bagdad
c'était la silicon valley de l'époque
c'est de là que vient le mot algorithmes
et le mot algèbre et l'envoyer dans les
deux cas il ya vraiment l'idée qu'on
extrait de la connaissance et que la
nature est au coeur de la cité au coeur
de la cité il ya un jardin
quel symbole du paradis ça c'est bagdad
avant le pétrole et bagdad avant le
pétrole était beaucoup plus riche que
bagdad après la bagdad creuset de la
connaissance
ce qu'ils vendaient au monde c'était de
la connaissance capitale mondiale des
mathématiques donc quand on extrait de
la connaissance
on est plus riche que quand on extrait
du pétrole et ça c'est pas nouveau
c'était valable à bagdad mais c'est
valable encore aujourd'hui pour apple
c'est valable pour facebook qui vaut 300
milliards en bourse alors que total vaut
total fait du pétrole facebook fait de
la donner si vous extrayez de la
connaissance vous êtes plus riche que si
vous exprimez du pétrole et je connais
pas un seul pays acp dans l'économie
soit basée sur la connaissance qu'ils
soient moins riche par habitant qu'un
pays dont l'économie est basée sur le
pétrole
donc quand vous creusez du pétrole au
bout d'un moment vous touché le fond
mais quand vous creusez de la
connaissance
à quel moment vous toucher le fond à
quel moment vous fait dire ça y est j'ai
extrait toute la connaissance possible
alors pour en revenir à la nature ça
c'est une diatomées et son squelette il
est en verre donc en oxyde de silicium
quand la nature fait du silicium ça
ressemble à ça quand nous en fait du
silicium ça ressemble à ça la mémoire de
vos téléphones ça ressemble à ça vous
voyez où je veux en venir
ça c'est la nature ça c'est nous ça
c'est une algue en fait et y en a dans
l'air là parce qu'on est suffisamment
proche de la maire pour qui on est dans
l'air ce sont des diatomées et elle
imprime le silicium mieux que nous
sommes vraiment dans une goutte d'eau de
mer vous avez des puces électroniques
intel corail seven qui flottent et elle
elle flotte en arguant depuis 60
millions d'années les bougresses parce
que ça fait 60 millions d'années que les
algues savent le faire donc la nature
nous met des claques en permanence
produits procédés la nature fait mieux
que nous donner un petit exemple tout
bête samsung et u17 petit sèche ce petit
c'est pioli de la samsung l'étudient à
votre avis pourquoi
samsung et c'est pas une animalerie
pourquoi il étudie ça de tous les
peuples de gaulle les belges sont les
prix bras je démarre pas ma bagnole en
rentrant chez moi on est d'accord
en fait c'est le meilleur écran connu
sur terre c'est le meilleur écran connu
sur terre on ne connaît pas d'écran plus
performant que cette petite sèche
on appelle ça un optical métamatériaux
donc il ya eu les led
il ya eu les amoled ya eu des plasmas il
ya eu lcd et les nouveaux écrans plats
en fait c'est ça concrètement je
plaisante pas c'est un taux de
rafraîchissement supérieur aux écrans
commerciaux on peut le chiffonné sa
s'auto répare ça consomme moins
d'énergie et aujourd'hui les grandes
sociétés qui fabriquent des écrans et
u17 petit sèche
donc vous imaginez en fait c'est un peu
comme si vous aviez un examen écrit
j'avais un examen et l'examen c'est les
nouveaux écrans disserter voilà vous
avez dix ans et dans cet examen bayal
élèves samsung y est l'élève lg via
l'élève apple qui sont là en train de
plancher pour essayer de résoudre le
problème
mais l'élève samsung dans sa poche il à
la petite sèche qui lui donne toutes les
réponses
c'est donc une antisèche
idrissa berkane humoriste mariage
première communion bar mitzvah bon le
sujet c'est ça la nature elle a un cv en
or en fait la nature il faut la recruter
si vous voulez la pauvre nature on l'a
attaquée sur son cv
1 on l'a attaquée on lui a fait croire
qu'elle n'était pas économiste par
exemple la nature est le meilleur
économiste sur terre il n'y a pas
d'économie ce plus performant que la
nature en fête aujourd'hui c'est elle
qui sait créer de la richesse
et si on crée de la richesse comme elle
on va être encore plus riche et sauf
qu'on va pas la détruire continue un peu
la visite vous ai dit la nature est une
bibliothèque
chaque organisme est un livre et dans le
livre et bien vous avez des paragraphes
avec des solutions techniques des
croquis d'architectes ce que vous voulez
un petit exemple tout bête quand je vous
ai dit qu'on va faire le cv de la nature
je vous montrais les prix qu'elle a
gagné déjà ça c'est un petit champignon
on l'appelle l'internet de la forêt y
connecte les arbres entre eux il prend
les déchets d'un arbre il les donne un
autre arbre sous forme de nutriments et
il se sert au passage qu'il a un
business modèle qui marche et ce
champignon il est capable comme ça de
connecter plein d'arbres entre eux eh
bien il ya un chercheur à oxford qui
s'appelle mark tricker qui a voulu le
tester pour voir un peu comment il
distribuait les choses alors il prend
une boîte de pétri et y met le
champignon à londres sur cette carte du
royaume uni donc il met le champignon à
londres et y met des morceaux des
flocons d'avoine sur les grandes villes
pour voir comment le champignon va aller
les chercher et y revient 48 heures plus
tard et il a une carte du réseau ferré
britannique meilleur que la carte
existantes
donc la carte existantes 150 ans des
générations d'ingénieurs 48 heures pour
un champignon beach
et ce petit machin jaune en fait il fait
en mathématiques ce qu'on appelle de la
théorie du transport c'est une théorie
mathématique qui a été créée par gaspard
monge au 19e siècle et les problèmes qui
relèvent de la théorie des transports du
transport sont très compliquées on peut
dire que la nature à la médaille fields
on peut vraiment dire ça elle a le prix
nobel de mathématiques si vous voulez la
médaille fields donc ça c'est déjà fait
sur son cv hockey voyons le reste la
tour eiffel parce que quand même au bout
d'un moment c'est un peu important
d'amener la civilisation d'henri pays
bon là tout à fait l'homme elle est plus
légère que le cylindre d'air qui la
contient elle est plus légère que si
elle voyait le cylindre d'air là-bas en
fait ils pèsent plus lourd que la tour
elle même et cette performance elle est
rendue possible parce que la tour eiffel
a été inspiré de l'oeil humain
les piliers porteurs de la tour eiffel
sont inspirés des os humains donc en
fait l'ingénieur dfl qui s'appelait
koechlin il avait étudié les zoos
humains en suisse
ça m'emmerde à chaque fois et il avait
découvert que les zoos humains sont
lacunaires sont très performants fait
les opaque humains d'oiseaux etc
ils mettent de la matière que là où il
ya de la tension donc en fait ils sont
creux ils sont essentiellement creuse ça
les rend très résistant et très léger
pour leur résistance
boum la tour eiffel où tout un tas de
points et c'est donc les naturel à un
prix pritzker aussi prix d'architecturé
ce petit coquillage
il est très toxique vous avez vu des
flashy déjà il est flashy dans la nature
en général ce qui est flashy et venimeux
c'est une règle c'est flashy venimeux il
ya plein d'animaux qui vérifie cette
règle les abeilles les guêpes les
amanite tue mouches kim kardashian la
reine d'angleterre roselyne bachelot et
est donc ce petit coquillage fait pas
exception
il est très très très toxique
à votre avis alors du coup sa molécule
sa toxine est très puissante et une
toxine puissante en biologie ça vaut
beaucoup d'argent je vais pas rentrer
dans les détails mais une toxine
puissante ça veut dire en fait qu'elle
est précise et une toxine précise ça n'a
pas de prix en biotechnologie du coup
elles vont une blinde
à votre avis combien
on va partir de l'or on va fixer la
barre très haut
ah les 35000 euros le kilo qui dit mieux
allez-y c'est pas comme si c'était votre
argent 1 millions + + fabien 6 millions
il y en a qui vont repartir avec l'âge
au 101 100 millions c'est plus vous avez
atteint la limite je vous laisse faire
le calcul 800 millions de dollars le
kilo l'or et le platine c'est du terreau
de jardin comparis non mais vous rigolez
mais c'est même pas une vanne en fait
c'est à dire que si vous vous amusez si
vous amuser à calculer le nombre de sacs
de terreau à géraniums que vous pouvez
acheter avec un lingot d'or
oui j'ai calculé ce chiffre ma vie c'est
de la merde
eh bien vous verrez que c'est le même
nombre de lingots d'or que vous pouvez
acheter avec un kilo de mu connaught
oxydes ce coquillage qui peut vous
produire parfois jusqu'à 1 milligramme
par mois eh bien il est vendu sur les
marchés
3 dollars comme souvenir à dire les mecs
le pech il le tue et puis ils le vendent
trois dollars comme souvenir là j'ai un
business modèle qui marche
alors imaginez je vous offre
je vous offre une bague tiffany dans une
boîte vous jetez là bas que vous gardez
la boîte si vous faites ça vous êtes un
chimpanzé techniquement
lascars sont apportés c'est rigolo la
boîte ça fait clap clap c'est marrant ce
bon un chimpanzé voulu filière un
bouquin voulu fouiller un bouquin pas
sérieux typiquement le mien fausse
modestie
de toute évidence eh bien ils le voient
comme un objet physique
la pauvre bête c'est par un objet
intellectuelle c'est un objet physique
dans la nature on la voit comme un objet
physique alors que c'est pas un objet
physique seulement c'est aussi un objet
intellectuelle la nature est un livre
encore une fois ce qui est précieux
dedans c'est ce qui est écrit nous la
nature on la voit comme un truc qu'on
peut manger ou qui peut nous manger donc
du convoi la dimension matérielle mais
la dimension immatérielle d'abord un
elle vaut beaucoup plus de pognon mais
deux justement si on la protège on ne
détruit pas la nature
si vous avez hérité une bibliothèque de
votre pp et la meilleure façon de faire
de l'argent avec c'est pas de la vendre
au kilo ces deux-là loué par exemple
c'est une bibliothèque faut pas vendre
des livres au kilo la nature c'est comme
ça qu'on la traite vraiment dire vous
avez hérité encore une fois de 15
étagères avec des bouquins dessus et
vous dites super g pouvoir devenir
marchand d'étagères c'est ce qu'on fait
avec la nature aujourd'hui au brésil on
la cram pour faire du soja
donc l'espace on va garder le foncier
puis tout ce qui était sur les étagères
on le brûle aucun intérêt la nature est
un sot l'y laisse géant je vous laisse
visualiser solide et sincère et qu'on
voit que la vérité sont des étudiants
qui ne sont pas connus le sol il est
c'est un bout du poulet et ça s'appelle
le sol il est ce parce qu'on le jette
alors qu'en fait c'est super bon voilà
tenez le vous pour dit ça va changer
votre vie ce genre d'information est
d'accord mais la nature on jette ce
qu'il ya de mieux
si la nature était une huître on
jetterait la perle en garderait la
coquine donc vous avez peut-être entendu
parler de ce projet c'est le radeau des
cimes
bah ça c'est peut-être si vous comptez
que la nature c'est une source de
connaissances et que la connaissance ça
vaut plus cher que le pétrole
et bien ça c'est nouveau derrick may
s'est pas dorst a peur que je pourrai pu
la faire cette vanne on est d'accord
il y en a qui se sentent coupables de
l'avoir comprise en il faut pas faire
jaillir la matière de la nature il faut
faire jaillir la connaissance la
conclusion de tout ça parce que la
nature en a vu dans quinze médailles
fields prix pritzker prix nobel de
chimie là avec son sa petite toxines en
fait ce que dit ce monsieur donc qui a
écrit ce bouquin c'est que la nature
aussi c'est le meilleur manager ses deux
meilleurs économistes
si on faisait comme la nature y aurait
pas de déchets parce que dans la nature
ya pas de déchets quand les feuilles
tombent des arbres on n'organise pas de
système de ramassage et en subventionne
pas les vers de terre
donc concrètement la nature elle arrive
à travailler sans déchets ce que dit ce
monsieur c'est déchets plus connaissance
égale richesse égale emploi mettons ça
en pratique le café en fait quand on
boit une tasse de café on n'utilise que
0 2% de la biomasse c'est débile le
reste et jetez y pourri fermente fait du
gaz qu'on récupère pas faim c'est pas
efficace en fait on peut cultiver des
champignons sur le café c'est le
meilleur mars est le meilleur champillon
poste au monde
le marc de café donc cette jeune fille a
créé une marque de café consignes et
donc le marais rendus disponibles par
exemple à rotterdam
ils ont réaménagé une ancienne piscine
en champignonnières donc ils prennent le
marc de café puis fonds cheetah khemaïes
attaqué ganoderma pleurotes qui on est à
rotterdam champignons magiques aussi
avec le marc de café vous pouvez faire
un textile qui tue les odeurs parce que
le café ça tue les odeurs donc ce
monsieur qui a créé la marque nescafé
eh bien il a un textile désodorisants
qui vend à des marques de sport mais
évidemment le mieux c'est en lingerie
c'est là qu'on marche le plus
je vous présente la main la marque
sorella j'adore leur slogan est appris
ton café aujourd'hui elle vous fait pas
rire cette blague là les blagues match
où tout de suite avec le marc de café on
peut faire un matériau aussi une sorte
de polystyrène je vous présente et ben
bailleurs et kevin mcintyre qu'on fait
un tel x d'ailleurs et l'ont fait sur
comment il arrive à faire ce bio
polystyrène à base de marc de café est
pas qu ils font pousser des champignons
dessus en fait concrètement donc ils
font pousser des champignons qui
envahissent le moule voyez le moule
derrière eux la suite envahi tac et ça
fait ce bio polystyrène complètement
biodégradable alors en résumé voilà la
nature
les belles et intelligentes est la prix
nobel de physique de chimie de médecine
d'économie de la planète prix pritzker
médaille fields ce que vous voulez elle
a un nba
c'est ce que dit gunter pauli un master
of brilliant adaptation et il faut qu'on
change la façon dont on la voit parce
que pour l'instant la maltraite mais il
est clair que si l'humanité divorce de
la nature elle pourra pas retourner
habiter chez ses parents c'est aussi
simple que ça c'est à dire que ou bien
on soigne notre mariage avec elle
bien c'est nous qui creuse comment nous
les humains on s'est appelé en tant
qu'espèce c'est quoi notre nom d' espèce
homo sapiens sapiens il ya plus d excuse
on s'est auto baptisé l'homme sage sage
il ya eu sapiens neanderthalensis qui
enterrait ses morts qu'avaient une boîte
crânienne supérieure à la nôtre 1,8 nous
c'est 1,3 mais nous on s'est auto
baptisé modestement homo sapiens sapiens
je gère n 6 alors la question c'est ça
qu'est l'homo sapiens on est est ce qu
on est homo sapiens matériel n 6 non on
a décidé de pas s'appeler comme ça ou
est ce qu on est homo sapiens sapiens
pour de vrai elle est pour conclure
j'aimerais me livre à une petite
expérience ne vais vous supplie j'ai un
peu dépassés l'avez vous fait ça vous
dégourdir les jambes en plus ça fait du
bien
ça vous êtes tous levés et ben vous tous
levés là comme ça vous tous levés bien
en rang est ce que vous savez ce que
c'est c'est la façon la plus fourbe
d'avoir une standing-ovation bien sûr
merci
ap